ah j'aime bien quand on m'envoie de tout
nouveau produit à venir découvrir et
aujourd'hui on parle d'un nouveau
produit de rugby alors il mijote déjà
beaucoup parler d'eux et demi j'avais
sur le mode qui est particulière c'est
le readme j'étais alors lorenzi gts
qu'ils aient coulé ce qui l'intéresse
ans tiens d'ailleurs il m'a envoyé un
petit ticket classement libre comme ça
je peux venir où je veux pour la pour le
découvrir
merci ennemis pour le ticket aujourd'hui
on sait ce temps tous vos smartphones de
rim me remy j en ai parlé et demi est
une marque propose des smartphones
intéressant à des prix très cool hyper
compétitif et qui les muscles et là il
est hyper musclé au niveau de la fiche
technique on a le meilleur processeur on
a les meilleurs ram on a une des
technologies de dingue de tous les côtés
des pour autant est-ce que ce smartphone
est super intéressant et je voulais tout
de suite il ya différentes promos ya
plein de propos je vous invite tous les
liens dans la description les voir parce
que il ya tellement de provoc tout est
marquée en bas et le tarif le moins cher
auquel on peut le trouver à son
lancement c'est 369 euros
après il sera un peu plus cher et sera à
449 mais ce qui est sûr c'est que pour
369 euros sur une période un petit peu
courte
vous avez le smartphone avec le
processeur le plus performant du moment
avec plein de technologies on va donc
regarder ce que sait faire ce rallye
j'étais qu'est ce qu'il ne sait pas ça
parce qu'il ne saura pas tout car je
voulais tout de suite à ce prix là il ne
peut pas savoir tout faire mais déjà
comme il est là rien qu'en regardant la
fiche technique
c'est hyper alléchant
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment l'impression d'avoir gagné
au loto je sais pas quoi avec un ticket
comme ça ou alors d'aller voir un match
peut-être d'aller voir un match bon
plutôt sympa tout se passe ici dans
cette petite boîte larry smith j'aime
bien la boîte le format est un peu long
c'est pas mal puis surtout ça change des
boîtes jeunes de rewmi donc pour le coup
ça c'est intéressant
alors j'ai déjà sorti le smartphone vous
vous en douterez mais je montrais
rapidement à l'intérieur ou welcome to
win mi-femme elissa c'est pareil un très
très grand classique
alors ici à l'intérieur de la boîte je
vais retrouver une petite coque pourquoi
parasympathique j'ai ici un petit câble
pour venir le charger en usb usb c est à
l'intérieur alors j'ai un bloc de
charges étrangers mais vous vous aurez
un blog français soyez tranquilles
c'est la super d'art charge on s'en
parle dans quelques instants alors
regardé et on pousse tout ça parce que
le smartphone faut que vous le montre le
smartphone il est là alors moi ce que
j'aime bien déjà c'est que c'est très
atypique c'est très particulier comme
look et c'est très typé on le voit comme
ça à regarder avec cette grande bande
noie sous ça assez original j'aime bien
leur côté positif de salah ces espèces
de cuir végétal c'est qu'en fait vous ne
prenez pas de traces de doigts vous
pouvez les prendre un petit peu ici mais
franchement c'est pas hyper déconnant ça
permet vraiment de bien intégrer le
module faut donc j'aime bien le design
sur la tranche le petit bouton ici avec
un petit côté je la regarde et là on
retrouve vraiment les couleurs ça marche
sur le dessus le petit micro pour la
réduction bruit ici vos boutons de
volume
ici une prise jack oui ça c'est bien ici
votre micro vote recharge en usb cécilia
haut parleur est ici vous pouvez mettre
uniquement une double sim pas
d'extension carte mémoire bon ça il faut
le savoir
gros point positif sur ce smartphone
c'est qu'il est très léger il fait à
peine 100 86 g je trouve aussi à ses
fins donc ça c'est assez intéressant
vous avez un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui déverrouille extrêmement
rapidement ça c'est bien il vous
retrouver ici un très grand écran c'est
un écran de 6,43 pouces super amoled un
super amoled samsung un écran full hd
plus et surtout ce qui est intéressant
ici c'est le taux de rafraîchissement
120 hertz et un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile de 360 m
qu'est ce que ça va apporter sa série
vraiment apporté en fluidité lorsque
vous allez faire des grandes parties de
gaming cardella vous laisser en
automatique comme ça il deviendra
choisir automatiquement switcher entre
soual 60r dans le soin leçon mayence
voilà c'est lui qui fait le taff où vous
embêtez pas et ici vous avez une gamme
de couleurs 100% dci p3 qu'est ce qu'il
nous raconte ce smartphone haut niveau
le doigt bien nous raconte qu'il a
haut parleurs stéréo plutôt bien une
fois de plus dans cette gamme de frites
premier haut parleurs voilà juste là la
sarre en connaisse un grand classique et
le deuxième qui est situé en façade et
bien écoutez quand même ça marche plutôt
pas mal et à l'écouter on s'énerve le
haut parleur vous avez la schola par un
haut-parleur de renforts c'est pas lui
qui a délivré les mac de son bar a
ajouté un peu en termes de
spécialisation et ça marche bien en plus
ici vous avez du bluetooth 5.21 avec
différents codecs à ptx à péter xhd hell
d'ac aacsb c vous pouvez donc vraiment
être compatible avec beaucoup de
produits en bluetooth est ici là c'est
tout du spectacle vous avez regardez
juste là là on le voit là là vous avez
une prise jack n'auront à la complète au
niveau de l'audio donc pour regarder des
films des séries déjà vous avez un bel
écran plus avez une bonne expérience
audio donc il ya moyen de se faire
plaisir et pour game illégalement et
pong et mig
oui pour le gaming parce que vous avez
un processeur extrêmement performant
snapdragon 888 c'est le processeur le
plus puissant du moment il y en a pas
d'autre voie là c'est celui là et si
vous avez soit 8 soit 12 giga de ram
c'est la rpd 10h05 pareille entente de
technologies sa tartine un axe vous avez
60 28 soit 256 go de stockage en ufc
trois points en autant vous dire que si
vous avez un combo gagnante pour toute
l'expérience de gaming et bien vous avez
un smartphone qui est performant ce
stade dragon 1188 il va être vraiment
très très bon pour la gestion de
l'autonomie c'est un de ses points forts
il apporte bien évidemment beaucoup de
paires tendance brut et il viendra en
plus
optimisez votre collection 5g la gestion
de votre réseau ici en interne parce que
oui si vous avez de la 5g et ça c'est
bien et en plus de ça lui il a également
du wifi 6 et en plus de ça il sait faire
un truc qui est vachement bien
il pas vous connecter en même temps à la
5 juin en même temps au wifi et puis à
faire sa petite tambouille interne pour
savoir qu'est ce qui va marcher un
minium moineau ce qu'il va dispatcher
pour vous ayez connexion réseau
extrêmement stable et proposer toujours
le maximum de bande passante et en plus
de ça il a un système de refroidissement
parce que ouais forcément va se douter
que lorsqu'on vient jouer à des jeux et
que sa tartine à max a maintenant il
risque de chauffer un petit peu vous
avez un refroidissement intérieur qui va
lui permettre de diminuer de quelques
degrés on sent un peu la chose sous les
doigts au bout d'un moment mais dans
l'ensemble c'est vraiment convenable à
l'intérieur on va retrouver une grosse
batterie de 4500 milliampères heures
c'est le grosse batterie grâce au stade
ragots 888 vous allez tenir un jour et
demi deux jours ça va dépendre de vous
aux usages si vous y allez comme un
dingue forcément vous en douterez et
bien les deux jours vous ne les aurais
pas si par contre vous jouez
raisonnablement vous avez des usages
mixtes films séries vous écoutez de la
musique vous jouez compagnie est bien là
dessus vous tiendrait sans aucun
problème donc ça c'est plutôt cool et
après vous avez de la charge très rapide
alors vous vous aurez un bloc de charge
français vous avez de la recharge 65
watts et la superbe d'arte charge
ça c'est très très très cool se permet
de recharger de 0 à 100 % seulement 35
minutes donc si vous manquez un peu de
batterie et bien hop là vous prenez ça
vous êtes tranquille et après il ya
plein de petits paramètres qui sont
super cools au niveau de votre batterie
pour ça vous venez ici dans batterie
vous avez différents modes allemande
économies d'énergie la vôtre super
économies d'énergie et puis après vous
aller encore plus loin dans vos réglages
vous allez voir venir encore plus
optimisé l'utilisation de votre batterie
ici vous aurez également une veille
optimisé ici avec un mode veille ultra
un mot d'équilibré pour moi j'aime il
maudit qui libre et ça ne paraît pas mal
puis il émis par des flambées c'est ce
qui me paraîtra pas mal ici figement
rapide d'une appli ses écrits si une
version blonde réduire la consommation
d'énergie des applications inactive en
arrière-plan
voyez pas mal de petites optimisations
logiciels et puisqu'on parle justement
le logiciel ici est bien ici vous
tournez sur risle me why 2.0 basé sur un
android 11
l'expérience est somme toute correct ça
marche bien on se repère assez
facilement si je viens par exemple si
dans réglages et luminosité d'un voyage
est un thème sombre un thème clair
s'associe très très cool et comme je
suis sûr de la molette donc de l'oled
quand j'ai un pixel noir saint pie x à
l'état cela permettra d'économiser
encore plus haut niveau de la batterie
pas mal de petits paramètres confort des
yeux j'adore mon moteur 0 ultra vision
pour améliorer par exemple la netteté
d'une vidéo claque juin cochet je peux
améliorer également la couleur de vidéo
enfin j'ai pas mal de petites options
que je peux venir activer/désactiver
j'aime beaucoup en tout cas l'expérience
eu le très bien au niveau de la photo
c'est là où ça va être un petit peu
moins fou fou
alors je vous montre regardez vous avez
3 capteur à l'arrière vous le voyez vous
un capteur principal c'est un 64
mégapixels il est planqué juste au
milieu et si les planques et là c'est la
caméra de sony c'est lit-et-mixe 682 ici
on ouvre à f 1.8 je vais avoir un ultra
grand angle qui est planqué jusque là
c'est un 8 mégapixels tout bref 2.3 avec
un champ de vision 219 degrés puis
devant une caméra macro qui est bloqué
ici c'est une 2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.4 tandis qu'à l'avant plan qui est
jusqu'ici j'ai une caméra de salfit 16
mégapixels qui rêvent 2.5
je veux voir pas mal de possibilités
photos vidéos photos de nuit le mode
portrait 64 mégapixels devenir touchait
directement et puis bien
avant bonbonnes ultra macro ici
forcément quand on a affaire à un
smartphone avec des specs aussi gonflé
et un prix tout moyen il ya un moment
forcément il a fallu faire des choix
alors le choix il a été fait ici au
niveau de la photo de la photo vous
allez voir avec globalement une telle
première chose que je veux venir lui
reprocher si c'est que vous n'avez
absolument aucune stabilisation optique
que de la stabilisation électronique
mais une fois de plus dans cette gamme
de prix
c'est pas très surprenant alors on
regarde tout est la première chose qu'on
voit sur la caméra principale c'est un
petit problème qu'on est au niveau de la
gestion de la lumière et que j'ai vu à
plusieurs endroits regardez ici là au
niveau de la fleur est bien déconner
delahousse lumière il a du mal et ne
gère pas très bien leurs leçons la can
est la principale sur la caméra de sony
et dès qu'on passe en ultra grand-angle
ouh là ça devient très très très dur on
a un côté déformant je trouve sur le
côté et là les hautes lumières il est
déjà plus du tout c'est pas terrible
terrible lors on peut se rapprocher
après en x 2 toujours ce problème de
lumière mais on peut faire un faux du
voile à 1 x 2 le x ça qu'on va pas trop
si tenté on peut faire un fois lisse
mais voilà c'est pas fait pour
ici c'est moins flagrant le problème des
hautes lumières ont pas sur l'ultra
grand angle
rien de plus à dire ici on se rapproche
jusqu'en fois simple faut 10
voilà vous le voyez également ici sur
les fleurs il ya du soleil alors y'a du
soleil il fait beau il fait chaud mais
problème de hautes lumières ici et c'est
vraiment le jeu tiré le gros point
négatif que je veux ni retenue récit
c'est que lorsqu'on fait des photos en
plein jour et qu'un beaucoup de soleil
il ne gère pas forcément très très bien
les ultra grand-angle est tout de suite
beaucoup plus palau par contre la caméra
principale je trouve assez saturé bon ça
peut donner du charme à vous de voir si
vous aimez d'ailleurs du club en bas en
commentaire on se rapproche problème de
notre lumière une fois de plus 6 6 x 2 x
5 ont doublé la caméra cette villa
trouve pas gg non plus il ya un espèce
de lissage aspects de traitement au
niveau de la peau qui me plaît pas
énormément et j'ai besoin d'avoir fait
je sais pas si c'est un beau tox avons
mis deux de la cire sur le visage voilà
je suis pas je suis pas extrêmement
convaincu parfaitement là on peut faire
la macro si on veut faut-il faire pour
autant de la macro je ne pense pas c'est
un choix qui a dû faire ici eh bien il
me choisir au niveau des capteurs il
fallait remettre en troisième est-ce
qu'on fait usuellement ici c'est vous m
un capteur macro alors ici c'est normal
il n'y a rien de surprenant
je suis pas hyper hyper fan c'est assez
terne moi ce que je vous conseille
davantage gallet cto de la macro cette
fois-là sais c'est pas terrible ya même
un peu de bruit si la voyance fait du
bruit numérique
moi ce que je vous conseille c'est de
prendre votre capteur principal mais
sans votre portrait savoureux sort bien
la photo
vous prenez votre caméra principale que
vous venez un peu zoomer dedans vous
aurez quelque chose de beaucoup mieux en
x 2 que venir chercher à faire de la
macro et ben x 5 on peut voilà bon on
peut même venir faire un peu de photo de
lui si on le souhaite mais une fois de
plus le rendu est pas dingue sur un
capteur principal ou sur l' ultra
grand-angle
en plus de ça sur l'avant vous avez un
double capteur de luminosité la neige
tombée dessus
vous avez un double capteur de
luminosité ce qui fait que si vous avez
beaucoup de soleil beaucoup de lumière
lui va s'adapter très facilement pour le
confort de vos yeux pour vous puissiez
toujours voir ce qui s'affiche
et en plus ici vous allez jusqu'à
minutes alors ministre c'est vraiment le
mc du max le plafond du plafond du
plafond mais lorsque vous à l'extérieur
et qui a beaucoup de lumière bon ça va
il fléchit pas c'est pas là où on verra
le mieux en plein soleil bien évidemment
en plein jour mais malgré tout ça fait
boum et vous avez également du fc pour
le paiement dématérialisé pour un petit
google paye et ce smartphone il est en
vente à la wii justement on ne dirait
pas comme ça vous avez plusieurs tailles
année c'est tout noté silence en blanc
accrochez-vous parce qu'on appelait
alors je me fais très très très
rapidement le tarif le plus intéressant
c'est sur les versions 8 +128 369 euros
sur alix presse du 21 au 25 juin
c'est vraiment sur les phases de
lancement dont dépêchez vous nous tenons
à votre agenda
vous trouverez également sur nba.com à
399 euros de 449 euros
les 21 et 22 juin mais également chez
amazon en version 12 plus 256 499 au
lieu de 599 les 21 et 22 juin donc vous
allez tous les liens en bas en bas dans
la description
s'il vous intéresse allez juste un petit
coup d'oeil et puis y'a pas d'autres
produits qui viennent d'arriver en ce
moment chez aurélie mis hors jeu montré
très rapidement vous avez des bugs sa
série bones herbe vous avez plein plein
de trucs et ils ont même faire tout ce
qui est assez surprenant et qui est très
sympa regardez je vous le montre c'est
un petit aspirateur robot parce que
ouais ils se mettent aliotti et pour la
maison connectée vous pouvez également à
faire appel à et demi alors je vais pas
vous le faire tourner c'est pas l'idée
ici mais regardez vous avez un petit
aspirateur robot qui est planqué là
dedans donc si vous voulez elle soit
pour cent et demi avec votre aspirateur
à la maison vous pouvez en plus il ya
plein d'autres produits il faut
également des montres connectés et
compagnie donc une fois de plus tous les
liens sont en bas dans la description
voilà pour ce que j'avais à vous
raconter aujourd'hui sur cinq produits
de rim me alors aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment le smartphone qu'on met
tellement parce que moi je trouve très
coup est ce que j'aime bien voyez c'est
d'avoir la performance brute un
smartphone extrêmement performant à un
prix très très bas alors il fera pas
tout il fera pas à boire et à manger
mais par contre ce qu'il fait il le fait
bien et ça c'est plutôt bien à vous
vous maintenant ce que vous en pensez en
bas on commente un moment où le trouver
ce rytme gts qu'il peut vous faire de
l'oeil oui ou alors absolument pas vous
de marquer ça en bas annonçant trouve
très très vite on va continuer à parler
tech parler de smartphones par les deux
heures et demie et puis paris plaine
chose parce que ça c'est super des
bisous d'amour pour le soin de vous et à
très vite à très très vite en masse
ciao